i have some rather upsetting personal
news that i'd like to share
oh no what's wrong well andy
i've run out of shows to watch you've
run out of shows to watch
yeah yeah this whole quarantine i've
been keeping myself
sane by binging lots and lots of shows
now i've run out i've literally seen
all the stuff oh come on there i mean
there's so many shows you can't have
seen all of it
let me recommend some more shows okay
try me i
i promise you i've watched everything
okay uh
you should check out ted lasso it's a
very funny show seen it
all right what about barb and star go to
vista del mar that's really funny
saw it well if you like sci-fi you
should check out the expanse
binge the whole thing uh bridgerton
inhaled it
eyes wide shut what the old movie where
tom cruise goes to an orgy
yeah watched it last night wandavision
all caught up wonder woman 1984. loved
it really
no saw it though shits creek more like
scenic creek
the great british baking show ready set
saw it
even the holiday special yes silvio's
fruitcake was a total train wreck
he deserved to be cut i you know agree
to disagree i guess
uh the marvelous mrs maisel it was
marvelous
the fantastic mr fox it was fantastic
the great gatsby
it was good oh come on conan there's no
way that you've seen everything
everything real housewives of orange
county saw it orange housewives of real
counties
seen it diners drive-ins and dives saw
it drivers diamonds and wives seen it
the masked singer
saw it the masked dancer saw it the mass
puppeteer seen it the masked mind sod
the masked genus
saw the mass ice skater scene rogue one
saw it
rogue two seen it two broke girls seen
two and a half men
saw two and a half broke man a broke
girl in a broke pizza place
scene unsolved mysteries saw unsolved
recipes
seen the queen's gambit scene the king's
fitbit saw
the duke's tidbit seen the czar's drill
bit saw
norbit scene the bachelor saw the
bachelorette scene the bachelorina song
bacheloreaux
bachelorette
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
saw harry potter and the chamber of
secrets saw harry potter and the phantom
menace
harry potter versus konk song the lord
of the potters the return of the harry
saw
avengers end game scene avengers and
table saw avengers endoscopy scene
avengers end of the year sale
seen it four times comedians and cars
getting coffee saw comedians on bikes
getting high scenes comedians in boats
getting brunch
scenes comedians on horses getting
divorced saw comedians in planes getting
bitten by snakes on a plane scene the
boys
saw it girls seen it golden girls scene
wait have i ever seen
the golden girls i don't think i have
let's see i knew we'd find something for
you to watch
man tonight i'm gonna go home and binge
the crap out of the golden girls
yeah and hey andy yeah
thank you for being a friend